[Music]
well nobody is dumping will and great
star Debra Messing because spoiler alert
everybody her character grace it's
single no more grace gets a boyfriend
boom that's right and I'm not allowed to
tell you who but you're gonna be so
Debra is sworn to secrecy until after
Will and Grace returns in October but
something she can reveal her dream guest
star I want Barbra Streisand to play
Grace's aunt you heard that I think
she'd do it I'm giving you eyes Barbara
I mean come on
but before the 49 year old signed on for
the reboot of Will & Grace she filmed
her first lead role in a feature film in
ten years
in searching Deborah plays a detective
I'm calling to report a missing person
okay who is this regarding my daughter
Star Trek's John Cho also stars in the
tech inspired thriller that is mostly
shot from the point of view of
smartphones and computer screens it was
so challenging because the entire film I
never got to act and look into John
Chows face you know the entire time I
was acting to a blank screen now are you
a helicopter parent at all do you
monitor social media oh yeah I mean he's
14 known I finally gave him a phone but
I said I can open it and look at every
text every search you make and you know
I said no Twitter no Facebook and at
some point you just have to trust your
kid and
pray
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]